notre histoire commence sous un grand
manteau blanc dans le chalet du vieil
homme préféré des enfants le père noël
assis à son bureau lisait toutes les
lettres de ces gentils marne
et lorsqu il leva son regard il vit deux
hommes et une femme avec de très joli
costard bonjour nationale je suis john
dilley pdg de quintiles pas si
mademoiselle mona de fisher games et
monsieur bill de le monde du jeu jouent
tous les enfants droit un joujou wimille
le gie seront que le père noël 30 à son
cou qui dans son verre de lait tout en
écoutant le charabia de la marchande de
chou et écoutez monsieur noël
l'économie mondiale ne s'est jamais
aussi bien portée alors votre artisanale
avez vos petits lutins c'est bien mignon
non 1957 monsieur noël
il faut passer à une production
industrielle plus massive a en ce sens
les grelots maintenant mes petits lutins
met beaucoup de coeur à l'ouvragé
fabrique suffisamment de jouer pour tous
les enfants sages ok ça rime ok mais
c'est complètement con être sage toute
l'année recevoir un cadeau pour être
récompensé tel est l'esprit de noël que
l'on retrouve dans chaque foyer sans que
sa vie tu me saoules mois alors
j'entends votre point de vue monsieur
noël mais j'attire votre attention sur
le fait que notre coeur de cible les 115
on est quand même majoritairement
composée de petits merdeux capricieux du
coup si on se prive de tous les enfants
pas sages quelque part on s'excluent
d'un marché assez lucratif
je ne vois pas ce que vous voulez dire
où voulez vous en venir nous
souhaiterions vous rachetez noël voilà
monsieur emmanuel non excusez moi tu vas
pas commencer à faire dire une fois
aussi me racheter de mal mais ça va pas
bien je viens à peine de le racheter aux
chrétiens la d afrique on perd sortie de
sa besace un contrat qui parlait
d'exclusivité de délocalisation et de
rachat en lisant ces mots le père noël
n'en revenait pas on voulait même
l'utiliser pour une marque de soda
les trois associés n'avait vraiment pas
l'air réglo le père noël se leva et leur
tournant le dos si je m'occupe de noël
c'est pour célébrer cette merveilleuse
nuit un soir dans l'année où l'on oublie
nos problèmes nos soucis où les familles
se retrouvent autour d'un bon souper où
les enfants s'amusent avec leurs
nouveaux jouets ou le plus vieux la
famille se retrouve me semble avoir
prévenu que j'en avais plein le cul des
rimes et puis ça sert à rien de discuter
avec des gens comme lui ils comprennent
rien s'il veut pas distribuer nos
cadeaux on dirait aux parents de venir
les chercher dans nos magasins puis
c'est terminé non qu'est ce qu'on fait
de lui maintenant alors moi j'ai
peut-être une idée le des trois compères
découper le vieil homme à la disqueuse
la tare plus galère est extrêmement
fastidieuse si je touche autres
plus ils balancent r les morceaux dans
la cheminée
quelque part le père noël connaissait
déjà le trajet les gens vous remarquez
qu'il a disparu vous finir par s'en
douter type aussi gentil que le père
noël ils se diront qu'il n'a jamais
existé alors sans déconner elle est
encore branché alors il va vraiment
falloir arrêter de m'emmerder avec les
rimes si vous voulez pas finir avec le
vieux là dedans
à tes bobos depuis tout à l'heure moi
une attitude s'est passé pas agréable
d'être ta compagne d'alors pousse à tuer
du lait
à